[Applaus]
[Musik]
hallo und shalom jeder weiß dass es sich
bei israel um ein sehr außergewöhnliches
land handelt ein land das sind viele
hinsicht aus der reihe tanzt in der
region also im nahen osten ist israel
die einzige wirkliche stabile demokratie
das einzige land in dem frauen rechte
auf westlichem niveau respektiert werden
und die einzige hightech nation welche
für die welt eliten aus dem silicon
valley oder china einen echten
wettbewerber darstellt israel steht
jedoch nicht nur in der region als
absoluter spitzenreiter in puncto
fortschrittlichkeit und
zukunftsfähigkeit hervor vielleicht hast
du dir da sie ja noch nie richtig
vergeben werde aber israel ist ein
entwickeltes land in denen die
alterspyramide doch wirklich wie eine
pyramide aus sieht ja israel verfügt
über eine gesunde demographie und eine
junge bevölkerung es muss also im
gegensatz zu china japan europa keiner
düsteren zukunft und einem kollaps der
rentensysteme durch eine überalterte und
kinderlose bevölkerung entgegen sehen
eine andere tatsache von der ihr sicher
schon gewusst hat ist dass israel über
eine der schlagkräftigsten armeen der
welt verfügt obwohl ist ein recht
kleines land ist die genauen gründe das
wird sind durchaus überraschend und wir
haben sie euch ja bereits in einem
anderen video ausführlich erklärt falls
sie jetzt noch nicht gesehen habt müsst
ihr es euch nachher unbedingt über den
link oben ansehen
fassen wir also zusammen israel ist
hochmodern bestens für die zukunft
gerüstet und vor allem eins extrem
wehrhaft und widerstandsfähig das ist
mit diesen eigenschaften welt weil immer
wieder eine spitzenstellung erreichen
kann sagt zum beispiel auch seine
unglaubliche erfolgreiche umsetzung des
programms gegen das krone wie du siehst
wurde israel mit seinen krone in
kampagnen zum weltweiten vorbild bereits
anfang februar 2021 als an zinsen
aufgrund mangelnden angebots in den
meisten industrieländern noch nicht zu
denken war hat nun bereits 40 prozent
aller israelis mindestens eine dosis des
impfstoffs gegensatz kopf 2 erhalten
doch damit nicht genug zu diesem
zeitpunkt war bereits mehr als ein
fünftel der bevölkerung israels dank der
impfstoffe vollständig immunisiert wir
sprechen hier von fast zwei millionen
menschen in einem land mit einer
bevölkerung von weniger als zehn
millionen einwohnern
wieder einmal hat israel bewiesen dass
es durch entschlossenheit tatkraft und
einigkeit herausforderungen meistern
kann an denen andere vermeintlich
hochmoderne und international angesehene
länder kläglich scheitern
genau durch entschlossenheit tatkraft
und einigkeit aber um mit mal so ganz
eigentlich scheint sich die israelis in
diesem fall nicht gewesen zu sein
israels politische spitzen streiten mit
ultra orthodoxen über carlos und
entführungen
tja es stellt sich heraus dass ein
entscheidender und immer größer
werdender teil der bevölkerung dieses
hightech langes er vor mittelalterlich
orientiert und ganz und gar nicht
gewillt ist mit dem rest der israelis am
stand des fortschritts zu ziehen
denn ultraorthodoxe juden stellen die
thora den text der die gesetze der
jüdischen religion enthält über alle
anderen aspekte des täglichen lebens die
fragen die sich nun stellen lauten also
welche konkreten auswirkungen haben die
starren religiösen traditionen auf den
lebensalltag dieser gemeinschaft warum
eigentlich streuen sie sich so vehement
gegen die maßnahmen die zur bekämpfung
des corona videos ergriffen wurden und
vielleicht die wichtigste frage von
allen welche probleme für die stadt
israel ergeben sich daraus dass die zahl
der ultraorthodoxen juden und ihr anteil
an der gesamtbevölkerung immer stärker
wachsen denn diese entwicklung wird
zweifellos zu einer immer größeren
herausforderung für die zukunft der
ganzen hebräischen nation heute werden
wir diese brennende frage hier auf
visual politik beantworten aber lasst
uns das so wie immer zuerst einen kurzen
blick in die geschichten verwerfen
jeder die vor gott zittern
[Musik]
es ist das einzige land der welt in dem
das judentum die mehrheitsreligion
darstellt 80 prozent seiner bürger
bekennen sich zur jüdischen religion
dies dürfte soweit keine große
überraschung für dich eigentlich war der
springende punkt jedoch ist dass man
nicht reden in einen topf werfen kann
nein da gibt es wie bei allen anderen
religionen gewaltige unterschiede
innerhalb des judentums gibt es
verschiedene strömungen strömung die
sich vor allem darin unterscheiden
die erste ihrer mitglieder ihrer
religion nehmen und wie intensiv sie
erleben danach ausrichten die meisten
juden israel sind kilo was auf hebräisch
einfach so cool er bedeutet denn in der
tagesdosen bin nicht vergessen dass
israel ein staat ist der hauptsächlich
von menschen mit sozialistischen idealen
geschaffen wurde
sie waren zwar alle juden aber sie
gründeten als deren start der von der
kirche getrennt ist natürlich ist auch
heute noch die bevölkerung israels
größtenteils säkular eingestellt einige
von ihnen praktizieren ein paar gälische
riten und traditionen aber ganz viele
noch nicht mal dass ich meinen das ist
etwas das ihr sicherlich aus jedem
anderen westlichen land kennt
[Musik]
aber genauso wie es jugend gibt die von
ihrer religion kaum beeinflusst werden
finden wir am anderen ende die
ultraorthodoxen juden sie nennen sich
kari den was auf hebräisch so viel
bedeutet wie diejenigen die vor gott
zittern eben die gottesfürchtigen aber
die tatsache dass es in diesem land eine
minderheit gibt die das jüdische gesetz
die thora in den mittelpunkt ihres
lebens stellt wäre nichts von besonderer
bedeutung und müsste uns auch keinerlei
kopfzerbrechen bereiten tja wenn diese
minderheit und die einfluss nicht
explosionsartig wachsen würden denn die
kinderreiche ultra orthodoxer
bevölkerung wächst gegenüber der
modernen er kinder hat uns die
politischen parteien welche die karre
den vertreten werden im politischen
leben israels immer mächtiger bis hin zu
jenen entscheidenden punkt an dem sie
den grundcharakter des uns bekannten
säkularen und modernen israel immer
verändern können
deswegen lautet die frage die wir uns
stellen nun die um alles levels konnte
das säkulare staat israel eigentlich in
diese vertrackte situation geraten nun
dafür müssen wir in die mitte des
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts reisen genau
die zeit als der staat israel entstanden
ist
[Musik]
im jahr 1948 proklamierte david ben
gurion die unabhängigkeit des staates
israel und wollte sein premierminister
eine seiner ersten entscheidung und
weist die bitte der rabbiner anzunehmen
die legendären regie wort europas in
israel wieder aufzubauen dies waren die
religiösen hochschulen des judentums an
der sich die meist männlichen schüler
dem studium der tora und des talmud
hingaben diese schulen waren in europa
während des holocaust zerstört worden
und israels politische führer sahen
damals das ultra oder doch zu judentums
war als einen anachronismus dass ich
überlebt hatte und sowieso bald
verschwinden würde
dennoch hielten sie es für angebracht
jüdische tradition die vom aussterben
bedroht waren zu schützen
die wort waren nämlich nur den
intelligentesten studenten vorbehalten
einen kleinen elitären zirkel werden wo
regierung rechnet damit höchstens 400
studenten nichts großes also daher hatte
er kein problem damit in ein privileg zu
gewähren welches im von feinden
umzingelt in israel damals beispiellos
war die komplette freistellung vom
militär ist womit man aber überhaupt
nicht gerechnet hatte war dass die
rabbiner jeden ermutigen würden in die
rabbinische schule zu gehen und genau
das taten sie dann auch
[Musik]
wie im traum wäre ben gurion in den sinn
gekommen dass die spieler ihre elitären
schranken heben und alle haben dazu
studium ermutigen würden und so gibt es
zurzeit mehr als 100.000 die gründe
nicht arbeiten und ihre tage mit nichts
anderem als dem studium der thora
verbringen und jetzt ihr euch vielleicht
wenn sie nicht arbeiten um geld zu
verdienen werde zahlt dann ihren
lebensunterhalt nun ich könnte euch die
antwort verraten aber vielleicht ist es
besser sich anzuschauen was ja kostmann
der gegenwärtig der führer einer der
wichtigsten ultraorthodoxen politischen
parteien ist oder auch der gegenwärtige
minister für wohnungsbau ist vor ein
paar jahren gesagt paradis abgeordneter
sagt männer brauchen nicht zu arbeiten
der frauen und der staat können für ihre
rechnungen aufkommen
genau das hat er tatsächlich gesagt und
so haben alle regierungen israels an
denen die parteien beteiligt waren dafür
gesorgt dass die sozialleistung für
kinderreiche familie und die staatlichen
unterhaltsleistungen für rabbiner
schüler immer mehr ausgeweitet wurden
und das ergebnis ist dass israel jedes
jahr etwa 300 millionen dollar aus dem
staatshaushalt alleine für isport
bereitstellt und das alles führt
natürlich dazu dass die cara die männer
außerordentlich fit sind was das wissen
über ihre heiligen bücher angeht aber
ganz und gar nicht zu dem arbeitsmarkt
wir hier mit leichtigkeit erkennen
kannst arbeitet die hälfte der
männlichen hat er dem überhaupt nicht
die weiblichen treten jedoch zunehmend
in den arbeitsmarkt ein
aber selbst diejenigen cara die männer
welche ihr einkommen durch bezahlte
arbeit verdienen können nur sehr bedingt
zum bruttosozialprodukt beitragen dass
ich von klein auf nur eine hoffnungslos
veraltete rein religiöse ausbildung
genossen haben jedoch keine moderne
welche sie in irgendeiner weise auf die
ausübung eines zeitgemäßen berufs
vorbereiten würde ist das spektrum an
arbeitsplätzen für ultra-orthodoxe sagen
wir mal etwas eingeschränkt wurde
zumeist sehr verkehrt denn ohne englisch
und mathe kommt man heute nicht weit vor
allem nicht in einem high tech land
außerdem können karten nicht einfach so
irgendeinen job machen sie dürfen nur
stellen annehmen bei denen männer und
frauen strikt getrennt arbeiten in der
kategorie schweres essen serviert und
der schabbat streng eingehalten wird
tja so ein paradis man das schon echt
schnell im leben die traumhaft leicht
und unbeschwert ist auf dagegen das
leben der frauen nicht sie müssen sich
ja neben den lebensunterhalt für die
ganze familie nur noch um den haushalt
und die kleinen racker kümmern und die
paar kinder gebären sich doch die von
alleine nicht waren schließlich hat man
ja gottes segen zwar besagt die mitte
also das gebot der thora dass eine
gottesfürchtige spa mit g 1 millionen
und einem mädchen seiner vor zwar nicht
bereits genüge getan hat allerdings
heißt das in der tufa weiter obwohl ein
mensch die mit zwar der fruchtbarkeit
und der vermehrung erfüllt hat ist er
durch ein arabisches gebots verpflichtet
nicht auf die fruchtbarkeit und die
vermehrung zu verzichten solange er
körperlich das so in der lage ist denn
jeder der dem jüdischen volk eine seele
hinzufügt wird angesehen als hätte er
eine ganze welt erst euro welche
wunderbare motivation zum zeugen vieler
vieler kinder
so sind ultraorthodoxe familie natürlich
groß im schnitt haben sie sechs oder
sieben kinder im gegensatz zu zwei
kindern eine durchschnittliche nicht
religiösen familien israel und dies
erklärt dann warum der anteil der parade
an der visuelle gesamtbevölkerung über
zehn jahren um ein drittel gestiegen ist
wohl zehn prozent im jahr 2009 auf 13
prozent im jahr 2020 und darüber
spätestens durch corona gelernt haben
was exponentielles wachstum ist kann
sich hier jeder 1 und 1 zusammenzählen
oder axe
[Musik]
bis zum jahr 2060 wird erwartet dass die
ultra orthodoxe jüdische gemeinschaft
mindestens ein drittel der bevölkerung
des landes ausmacht genau das ist das
minimalste mario denn so wie es aussieht
kommen heute bereits 25 prozent der
erstklässler in israelischen
grundschulen aus ultra orthodoxen
familien sind jedoch nicht nur in
grundschulen überproportional vertreten
aufgepasst
[Musik]
obwohl die karibik heute nur 13 prozent
der gesamtbevölkerung ausmachen
gerade in ihrer gemeinschaft ein drittel
aller komik 19 infektion israels auf und
auch wenn es nicht einfach zu beweisen
ist was der grund dafür sein könnte
so wurden sowohl in den mainstream
medien als auch in den sozialen
netzwerken immer wieder fotos und videos
verbreitet die große ansammlungen von
cara dem eng beieinander betend ohne
jegliche sicherheitsabstände und
natürlich unter totale missachtung des
auch in israel gelten des
versammlungsverbots von mehr als zehn
personen zu sehen war es weiter april
2020 ultra orthodoxer israelis als
minister positiv auf das virus getestet
nun natürlich muss eine
gesundheitsminister keine rede sein um
sich das kronos einzufangen das wissen
ja alle nur zu gut allerdings gibt es
doch einen großen unterschied wären sich
überall so uns die politiker mit kroner
infizieren weil sie wasser predigen und
wein saufen sind die ultraorthodoxen
ganz offen und ehrlich als 2020 alle
bildungseinrichtungen israel geschlossen
wurden durften g j und synagogen
weiterbetrieben werden weil ich habe dem
sagten dass die thora die gläubigen
schützt und rettet der großteil der
israelischen bevölkerung ist über so
viel gottvertrauen nicht gerade
begeistert fall wenn sich darunter noch
eine gehörige portion ziemlich abgedreht
hat es information mischt ultraorthodoxe
habe erzählt anhängern dass der korona
impfstoff menschen schwul machen kann
unter normalen umständen wären diese
worte aus dem mund eines spinners nicht
mehr als eine anekdote wert allerdings
muss man bedenken welchen schaden ein
rabbiner anrichtet dass so was in der
ultra orthodoxen gemeinschaft verbreitet
[Musik]
werden wer von den rabbinern ausgeübte
einfluss auf die karibik ist brutal es
ist ihnen zum beispiel verboten
fernseher oder radius zu besitzen es ist
ihnen zwar erlaubt handys zu kaufen aber
wie ihr dieser grafik entnehmen könnte
ist das zugang zum internet eine ganz
andere sache
all dies macht es den
gesundheitsbehörden extrem schwer diesen
teil der bevölkerung zu erreichen
viele karten erhalten zum beispiel nicht
die textnachrichten durch weil sie
kontakte mit kuwait positiven personen
verfolgt werden sollen hinzukommen
optimale ausbreitung bedingungen zur
krone
die für alle anderen arten von
krankheitserregern es ist nicht schwer
sich das alles vorzustellen große
familie wenig finanzieller spielraum
viele der ultra orthodoxen familien
müssen daher in überfüllten wohl sein
leben und auf religiöse feiern
verzichten wollen sie schon gar nicht im
jahr 2020 noch mit tausenden von
menschen und der massenfertigung von
rabbi alexander wetzig teil was den
derzeitigen verteidigungsminister wenn
die ganz die zornesröte ins gesicht
so sieht ungleiche durchsetzung aus
millionen von familien und kindern sind
in ihren häusern eingesperrten halten
sich an die regeln
wir haben sich tausende von
ultraorthodoxen auf der beerdigung
trennen die meisten von ihnen sogar ohne
masken werden der fortsetzung eines
unwirksamen lockdown nicht zustimmen
entweder zu schließen dass wir alle oder
für öffnen für alle die tage der
nachsicht sind vorbei wieso aber ist
eine durchsetzung der lockdown maßnahmen
unter dem car at dem konkret zu
schwierig die wahrheit ist dass die
behörden einfach angst haben zu handeln
denn jedes mal wenn sich polizeikräfte
den ultraorthodoxen menschen männer
näherten bastelte buchstäblich ein
hagelsturm aus steinen auf ihnen nieder
noch größer ist allerdings die angst vor
den ultraorthodoxen auf einer ganz
anderen ebene der politischen
einflussnahme und diese geht so weit
dass sie dann direkt auswirkungen auf
alle anderen bevölkerungsteile hat egal
ob jemand streng gläubig ist oder nicht
gesundheitsminister will impfangebot
sieben tage die woche 24 stunden am tag
aber kooperativ sind am schabbat dagegen
wieso in aller welt sollten die rabbiner
bestimmen welchen tagen geimpft alter
oder nicht nun am ende setzte sich der
minister durch aber
er musste sich dafür ganz schön rein
hängen und sich auf ein besonderes
prinzip berufen dass nico ach das ist
ein begriff aus dem jüdischen recht so
genannten cara und dieses prinzip besagt
dass die erhaltung des menschlichen
lebens steht der andere religiöse regel
außer kraft setzt das muss man sich mal
auf der zunge zergehen lassen eine
demokratisch legitimierte regierung muss
sich mithilfe uralter religiöser gesetze
dafür rechtfertigen dass sie ein ganz
und gar westliches vorhaben der
gesundheitspolitik umsetzen will aber
den rabbis war dies noch nicht genug
ihre machtdemonstration ging noch weiter
zuerst sagten sie dass die situation
nicht ernst genug sein um das ego
anzuwenden
danach wollten sie einen plan beweist
dass die übrigen sechs tagen der woche
die uns weil sie stunden am tag voller
pulle längst wird diese zeit sollte ich
nicht ausreicht um allen verfügbaren
impfstoff zu verabreichen
erst dann dürfe man auch am schabbat
impfungen durchführen und am ende waren
sie sich nicht zu blöd zum verlangen
dass wenn am schabbat schon geimpft
würde ist aber auf jeden fall verboten
sei die daten der gift passieren so
erfassen wie natürlich die fahrt zum
zentrum selbstständig vorher europa
müsste eine regierung mit irgendwelchen
bibelzitaten ich hab gesundheitsvorsorge
gegenangriff von bischöfen verteidigen
nun zum glück für israel ist hat sich
ihr regierung zwar erniedrigen lassen
indem sie sich auf mittelalterliche
weise rechtfertigen musste letztlich
jedoch in der sache durchgesetzt israel
wurde weltweit zum großen vorbild dieser
angewohnheit von grün bis mitte februar
2021 waren sogar in wohngebieten mit den
mehrheit 72 prozent der menschen über 60
gekämpft das waren in dieser
altersgruppe nur acht prozent unter dem
nationalen durchschnitt und die
machtkämpfe zwischen der religiösen und
weltlichen politik bezüglich gerona sind
nur ein beispiel von vielen denn diese
ziehen sich durch die israelische
gesellschaft wie ein roter faden und
nehmen immer weiter zu und glaubt mir
dabei geht es nicht nur um den schabbat
nein es geht und durch und durch
existenzielle fragen die ihr fragt euch
was ich damit meine nun lasst uns mal
etwas tiefer in diesen sumpf eintauchen
[Musik]
der schlüssel zur knesset
die wahrheit ist die orthodoxen juden
wollte nie dass der staat israel
gegründet wird der schaden ist der
zionismus und die unterwerfung oder
zivilen autoritäten eine art ketzerei
was musste ben gurion also tun um die
damals notwendig unterstützung der ultra
orthodoxen rabbiner für einen
unabhängigen staat israel dennoch zu
bekommen nun das was politiker auch
heute immer wieder tun
sie machen zugeständnisse er versprach
ihnen zum beispiel dass der öffentliche
dienst am schabbat nicht arbeiten würde
jeden am sichtbarsten wird dieses
öffentlichen personenverkehr seit mehr
als 70 jahren stehen alle busse und
bahnen in den meisten fällen israels vom
sonnenuntergang am freitag bis zum
samstagabend still und leer was sich ja
vorstellen könnt hat eine überwältigende
mehrheit der israelischen bevölkerung
die nase voll davon jedes wochenende
damit konfrontiert zu sein dass viele
dinge die sie gehen unternehmen würden
am schabbat einfach nicht gehen
[Musik]
aber es gibt durchaus bewegung in dieser
sache so zuletzt ende 2009 10
überlaufene busse aus tel aviv den
öffentlichen nahverkehr am schabbat
einführt diese kommunale initiative
wurde ein erfolg und von anderen städten
kopiert es bleibt jedoch abzuwarten ob
dieser widerstand gegen die religiösen
auf dauer aufrechterhalten werden kann
da nicht finanzierung der öffentlichen
einrichtungen er vom innenministerium
abhängt und bisher verstanden es die
kadettin ausgezeichnet wie sich die
tatsache zunutze machen können dass
israel in den letzten zwei jahren keine
solide regierung hatte in diesen zwei
jahren mussten die wähler das parlament
ganze vier mal neu wählen
zuletzt ende märz 2021 wobei auch dieser
letzte war wie schon die drei
vorhergehenden keine eindeutigen
mehrheiten zustande brachte deshalb
erneut eine sehr schwierige
koalitionsbildung beziehungsweise
abermals neuwahlen in wenigen monaten
erwartet werden der politische druck der
ultraorthodoxen wir zu den meisten
israelischen bürgern gelinde gesagt als
nervig empfunden
sogar von einem guten teil der rechten
konservativen wählerschaft die krux ist
jedoch dass die unterstützung der carrer
die parteien oft entscheidend ist damit
überhaupt eine regierung gebildet werden
kann
in israel ist nun mal eine
parlamentarische demokratie in welcher
der premierminister von der mehrheit der
knesset das heißt von mindestens 65 der
120 abgeordneten gewählt wird das
israelische parlament ist stark
zersplittert seit 30 jahren hat keine
politische partei mehr als 40
abgeordnete bekommen die
eintrittsschwelle ins parlament liegt
bei 3,25 prozent und so haben ist auch
nach der letzten mal wieder ganze drei
zählt dateien in die knesset geschafft
dies erfordert eine hochgradig
komplizierte bildung von
koalitionsregierungen mit vielen
verschiedenen parteien ja und wie ihr
sicher wisst müssen dabei alle
koalitionspartner irgendwie bei laune
gehalten werden
mit allerlei zu gestalten dass man
futtertrögen und pöstchen in einigen
israelischen regierungen wurden deswegen
bis zu 30 minister posten geschaffen und
es ist natürlich auch sehr verlockend
eine regierung mit der unterstützung der
ultraorthodoxen so bilden der die zwei
cara den parteien kommen normalerweise
auf etwa 15 parlamentarier und das sind
15 mehr
um an die 61 jahren zu kommen und was
denkst du ein paar kleines zugeständnis
an die ultraorthodoxen die das hat mode
von westlichen verkehrsmittel schabbat
wir haben keinen eindruck dann kann ich
dir versichern dass es entkernt und
wesentlich brisanter existenzielle
fragen geht dann wie du sicherlich weist
ist israel ein land das von ihm
feindlich eingestellten staaten quasi
umzingelt ist einige von ihnen würden es
umgehend auslöschen wenn sie nur könnten
das heißt ein israel nicht hochgradig
unbedingt ab der bereit wäre
die uneingeschränkte funktionsfähigkeit
der israelischen armee der edf ist für
jeden israeli im wahrsten wortsinne eine
frage von leben und tod daher unterliegt
jeder bürger israels einer wehrpflicht
von mindestens zwei jahren
tatsächlich ist israel eines von und
neun ländern auf der welt in dem auch
frauen sehr wichtig sind sogar wonder
woman hat militärdienst geleistet okay
nicht darum sondern kalkar durch welche
jetzt so kuriose nachrichten wie diese
hier provoziert hat wonder woman im
libanon verbotenen wald
hauptdarstellerin israel ist fakt ist
dass alle israelischen bürger
verpflichtet militärdienst zu leisten
wirklich alle
nein die religiöse gemeinschaft der
unnachgiebigen cardin widersetzt sich
der werft nicht bis heute
sie wurden von ihr genauso wie die
israelischen araber mit ausnahme der
dosen ja schon bei der staatsgründung
befreit und freiwillig leisten nur sehr
wenige paraden die zweieinhalb jahren
dies vermindert und zwei jahre für
frauen
was die mehrheit der israelischen bürger
ziemlich uns solidarisch findet wenn
alle anderen müssen ja ihr studium oder
ihre karriere unterbrechen um der
landesverteidigung zu dienen und das war
ein hoher lohn zwischen 80 und 250
us-dollar im monat während eine cara die
familie locker auf monatlich 1400 dollar
an sozialhilfe kommt und zwar ohne
aufenthalt eine weise dazu beizutragen
dass israel weiter existieren kann und
sich selbst überhaupt lebensgrundlage
haben ja sogar dem israelischen obersten
gerichtshof buddies alles dann doch zu
bunt und so hat er bereits zweimal
geurteilt dass gesetze die
ultraorthodoxe juden vom militär dieses
befreien diskriminierend und
verfassungswidrig seien
die obersten richter setzten der
regierung jedoch erst einmal eine frist
für die verabschiedung einer nicht
diskriminierenden regelungen und ziel
ist es die karre dem behutsam und
schrittweise in dem militärdienst
einzugliedern und dabei alle ihre
besonderheiten und befindlichkeiten zu
respektieren also ihr wisst schon
schweres essen absoluten räumliche
trennung von männern und frauen und so
weiter
aber welche bereits erwähnt habt hat
israel seit zwei jahren keine solide
regierung mehr und die frist der
obersten richter ist längst abgelaufen
nach neuesten informationen wurde eine
letzte verlängerung beantragt
generalstaatsanwalt fordert universelle
edf einberufung für den hcd sektor am 6
juli
dieses thema hat alle chancen eines der
hauptthemen auf den verhandlungstisch
der nächsten israelischen regierung zu
sein
wir werden dieses thema hierbei diese
politik auge behalten und wir werden
euch mehr über die herausforderungen
berichten welche diese gemeinschaft zu
die zukunft des staates israel bestellt
werden da gibt es noch so einiges über
das wir reden müssen
vergesst also bitte nicht unseren kanal
schnell zu abonnieren denn ihr glaubt
mir es wird noch viel spannender
es gibt noch sehr viel zu sagen über all
die probleme welche israel durch und mit
dem fahrrad dem hat und noch kommen wird
das fängt damit an dass kein soldat sein
eigenes essen mitbringen kann dadurch ja
nicht koscher sein könnte und sich
dadurch eine zufällig anwesende
religiöse person beleidigt fühlen könnte
denn das wäre ja das schlimmste was
eines soldaten passieren das gleiche
gilt übrigens für alle patienten im
krankenhaus während des pessach fest
kein eigenes essen egal ob man religiös
ist oder nicht
weiter geht es damit erst mal als jude
auch als nichtreligiöse nur heiraten
darf wenn man dabei den vollen
orthodoxen richtungs einhält und das ist
nicht nur irgendeine kleinigkeit wenn
sie braucht zum beispiel musste war
immer ein tauchbad die mikwe absolvieren
egal ob sie will oder nicht sonst gibt
es keinen trauschein
und auch wenn eine ehe scheitert mischen
sich die rabbinerin es reicht dass nur
einer der ehepartner eine klage beim cas
den rabbiner gericht einreicht dann
wären alle streitigkeiten die
schließlich scheidung unterhalt und
sorgerechtsfragen dort verhandelt und
das urteil ergeht genießt der halle h
den jüdischen religionsgesetz nicht
gemäß brot deren uns nicola an gesetzen
die im säkularen zivilrecht vorgesehene
gleichberechtigung der geschlechter und
schutz vor diskriminierung sind somit
nicht gewährleistet wie ihr seht ist
israel also auf der einen seite ein
modernes aufgeklärten dynamisches land
wird auf der anderen seite jedoch durch
eine mächtige streng religiöse
minderheit mit acronis tischen
wertvorstellungen in atem gehalten mehr
über diesen riesigen widerspruch erfahrt
ihr aber demnächst in einem anderen
video hier auf besucher punkten schreibt
uns bitte eure meinung in die kommentare
unter diesem video immer sind wir auf
diesen schon hochgradig gespannt ich
hoffe dass euch dieses video gefallen
und auch etwas gebracht hat falls ja
geht uns bitte eine kleine slide
unterstützt uns in den inhalt und
vergesst auch nicht das abo shalom und
macht's gut bis zum nächsten
[Musik]